Welcome back. So now that we have a fair bit of background in the theory behind data analysis,
in this video what we're going to do is start getting our hands dirty with some of the tools
and libraries available in Python for data analysis. So first we are going to start with
data structures and data types. These are essentially objects inside a programming language
that help you contain your data and that help you store and access your data properly. So they are
broadly called data structures. The most common data structure or the most useful data structure
that we have in Python is called simply a list. So this is simply a linked list for those of you
who come from a programming background and they can simply be created by putting a bunch of things
separated by a comma inside a list of inside a pair of square brackets. Some of the things to
remember is that a list is an object which can contain multiple data items obviously and they
are mutable. What this means is that once you create a list you can keep on endlessly changing
it, modifying it, editing it. So you can also use them as temporary data storage devices. You can
use them to include variables or data points whatever you like and they can change in the
course of a program's execution. They're also dynamic in the sense that items may be added or
removed from them as and when you like depending on whatever program you like. The biggest advantage
of lists is that they are heterogeneous in the sense that they don't create any restrictions in
terms of what kind of objects can go inside them. You can add numbers, you can add text, you can add
floating point values, booleans, any type of data that you can imagine in Python you can add it to
a list. Now this makes a list very flexible but it also makes it a little slow. Since these are
linked lists if I have to find the second item in a list I have to first find the first item. Of course
I don't have to do this manually. Python does it internally but since this is a linked list what
happens is if I am looking at say the kth item in a particular list I need to know the sequence
that comes before it because the only way I can reach a given data point or a given item in a
list is if I traverse through the preceding lists of items in the whole list basically. So I can't
randomly pick a particular item from a list. The reason why this happens is that you know since
lists are heterogeneous and they can contain any kind of data and since it can contain multiple
types of data the memory that is taken up by each type has a different size. So for example if I
store only a list of integers then I know that each and each integers can take anywhere from 8 to 64
bytes. So therefore I can calculate where a particular integer lies because let's say that
I have a list of 15 integers and I want to pick the fifth integer then I know that it's going to
be at 5 into 64 bits from the beginning of the list. So I can directly jump to that but since
lists are heterogeneous that is they allow multiple data types to be contained within them it's not
possible for me to do that calculation. Let's see how that actually matters later in the program.
So this is a simple way of creating a list you simply create a pair of square brackets and put
things inside them. In this particular case we are putting three strings inside a list. A string
in Python is anything that appears within double or single quotes. So it doesn't matter whether
I use a double quote or a single quote it's basically a piece of text or a string and I
can just put commas between two separate items. So this becomes a list which has three strings
inside it the first of which is apples the second is oranges and the third is cherries. So let's run
that and yeah that's basically what my list looks like. We can also add you know you can
assign that to an output variable. Here we have a new list which contains four strings let's
pretend that they are product numbers in my stock inventory or something like that and then that
becomes my list again. So I can just do something like this and that's my list again. Just like we
have strings we can also have numbers in this case let's say that we have sales by month for
four months so I have four numbers over here. So I can just add them to this list called sales
by month and there it is. You can also have nested lists in the sense that we have already
decided that a list an element of a list can be anything. We saw that it's a string we saw
that it can be a number or an integer it can be a whole list by itself. So a nested list is nothing
but a list which contains other lists. So we see that this sales by season is a list which
contains four other lists right and you can see that each of those sub lists has three elements
each and there are four of them so you can imagine this like a three by four table. So that's also
just as easy to create basically to reinforce lists make no restriction on what sort of data
it can contain you can pretty much add anything. So let's say that we have a simple exercise here
we have to create a list which stores your name your age and your gender. So pause the video and
try it out. Well it's simple enough I can just create say and I'll create a list and let me call
it some suitable variable I say something like mighty teams and first thing I need to do is
create a pair of square brackets because that's the syntax for creating a list. Now what I want
to store is my name age and gender my name is obviously going to be a string so I'll write my
name my age now age can be an integer so I'll write my age my gender again can be a string which
is male in this case but you can write something like that or you know you can actually write out
the whole thing as well right so that's simply my list. So let's talk about what are some of the
common operations on list one of the most common things that you do with the list is try to find
the length of a list so we have this list called sales by month and we can see that its length is
four but that's because I have the source code for that list right in front of me what if I don't
know how this list was created but I still need to find out its length in a programmatic way I can
just use the length function to do that so I just call the length function and give the list as the
input and it's going to give me the length so let's try that and it says that the length of that
list is four one two three and four right now how do I access a particular element from the list well
I just use the name of the list followed by a pair of square brackets and inside that square
brackets I give a position so that will just that's just going to give me the element that
corresponds to that position remember that in Python counting starts from zero so basically
this particular element is not the first but the zeroth element of the list this then becomes the
first this becomes the second and this becomes the third right and what if I want to change a
particular thing well I just add the position indexer and assign it to a given value so I have
the first element of sales by month was 180 but if I set it to 230 and I print out the list again
here's what I'm going to get so there it is you see that it has gone from 180 to 230 over here so
this is how I can modify a given position in a list another very useful and important operation
on a list is called slicing or indexing sometimes I am not interested in getting a single value out
of a list but a range of values so let's say that I have a list and I want to get the first to the
third value now for that I can use the syntax I can give the starting position then I can add a
column and then I can give the ending position now this works in a slightly funny way the ending
position is not where it stops actually it stops just one shot of the ending position so it's
basically if I want the i-th to the j-th position in the list my syntax will be something like
i colon j minus 1 or basically j plus 1 so it's going to be stopping just one shot of whatever is
the last position so let's check check it out how it works if I have one is to three what this is
going to give me is the first and the second but not the third because it stops one shot so it's
supposed to give me 180 360 but however the first one we have already changed so it's going to give
me 230 and 360 so basically it's going to slice this list and let's run that so you see that we
get 230 and 360 the idea is that you start with the first element after the colon whatever is the
element you stop one shot of that so if I can also modify this the syntax a little bit I can
say that I want the first three digits so then I just omit the starting position and it's just
going to give me the first three elements of the list so there it is it gives me 250 230 360 just
copied over here I can also do something like give me everything from the second element onwards
now the second element here is 360 because again remember that counting starts with 0 so here in
this case we are going to get 360 and 340 let's try that and there it is right and let's say that
I want the second to the last element so I can basically do one remember that again counting
starts with 0 so the second element is actually the first in Python I can go all the way up to
4 because 4 doesn't exist obviously so it's going to short one stop of it's going to stop one shot
of that anyway so in this case I'm going to get 230 360 and 340 we already have some idea of how
we can create lists but one quick way of generating a list from another type of data structure which
is still sequential is using the list function and the range function is something which is a
special function in Python which creates a range of integers so when I say that I want a range of
all the integers from 2 to 20 I can use this syntax as again with the slicing here also in
the range function the range is going to stop just one short of we already know one way of
creating a list that is enclosing items within square parenthesis but there are some other ways
of doing it as well one of them is to use the list function what the list function does is that it
takes as an input anything that is a sequence of objects and converts it into a list and one of
the things that we can use to create a list of integers is the range function the range function
simply takes a couple of integers as an input and what it's going to do is starting from the first
input and ending all the way up to the last input minus 1 it's going to create the list of those
integers so essentially what I want to do is if I want to create a list of all the integers starting
from 2 and going all the way up to 19 I can use a range function like this remember that range works
similar to the indexing part it essentially starts with a particular number and whatever is
the next number it can go all the way up there minus 1 so this is going to give me a list of
all the integers from 2 to 19 right and what I can do is here my step size was 1 because I didn't
add any third operator over here I just said 2 comma 20 which means that it's going to take
1 as the default step size I can change this default step size as well let's say that I want
every even number from 2 to 20 so that I can add a third argument which becomes my step size
so if you add only two arguments it's going to interpret as start and stop plus 1 and if you
add a third argument it's going to interpret that third argument as the step size that is the number
of numbers it should skip while creating the list so let's take a look at how that works so you see
I have all the even numbers from 2 to 19 remember that 20 is still skipped because it's supposed to
stop one short of 20 okay note that the stopping position is excluded now my list is basically all
the even numbers from 2 to 19 and what I'm going to do here is take second third fourth and fifth
I won't take the sixth right so I can just do 2 colon 6 and I'm gonna get something like 2 4 6 8
out of this so there it is no remember that now again let's try some indexing on the newly
created list of even numbers that we have we are asking it to take the second number all the way
up to the fifth number so let's do some slicing on the newly created list that we have over here we
wanted to take the second number all the way to the sixth number or actually the fifth number
because the last position will be excluded and since counting begins from 0 we are going to start
from 6 and go all the way to 6 8 10 12 essentially so let's try that and that's what we get now
remember that this step notation that we have over here the moment you specify a third integer it
becomes a step position we can also apply that to slicing when I say a colon B it will just take
everything from a and in incremental steps of 1 go all the way to B minus 1 but if I add a colon C
as well a third integer as well it's going to take that as again the step size so basically I'll get
this but it will again within this skip every other element so essentially here I'm going to
get something like 6 and 10 so there we are so we just get 6 and 10 which is basically a slice
of this particular data set but with every second element skipped so you see that the
range syntax and the indexing syntax are more or less quite similar here's the next exercise
let's create a list of the first 20 positive integers and slice it to find all even numbers
feel free to pause the video over here and try it out so let's try it we want a list of first
20 positive integers so I'll do something like call the list function and inside it add range
I need to start from 1 and I need the list of the first 20 positive integers so I'm going to stop
at 21 and then I'm just going to slice it to give me all the positive integers so I'm going to go
from 1 to 21 in second in orders of by skipping every other integer so that's it that's what gives
me the list of first 20 positive integers and then I slice it to find all the even numbers so
let's look at some of the other more complex operations on list the first being joining list
so basically let's say that I have some data for the first four months of the financial year which
are my sales and obviously new data is going to come over so I have the data for the next few
months I can just add lists by using the plus operator I can just do sales by month plus sales
new now what the plus equal to operator is going to do is simply append the two lists and write the
output in the original list itself so I can do if I have a list say sales by month and another one
called sales new I can do sales by month plus sales new but that's going to give me a third
list if I just want to increment this list which is simply to add numbers at the end of this I can
use this plus equal to operator so let's try that and there it is so basically I have the sales by
month and these are my sales new and sales by month gets updated to include the whole list not
just it just doesn't remain limited to this of course if I wanted a third variable to contain
the concatenation of these two lists then I could have used simply the plus operator without the
plus equal to syntax here's a simple exercise to basically figure out whether an element is in a
list or not so another very important operation that we do on a list is membership we essentially
try to check if a given number or a given element or a given object is present in the list or not so
let's say that we are running an e-commerce business and we have a bunch of product numbers
so these are our product numbers and what we're going to do is ask the user for an input say enter
product number and we are going to say that if we are going to whatever the user inputs we are
going to assign that value to a variable called search and if search is in product numbers then
we can just say we found this product otherwise we haven't found this product now the idea is
that in order to search for membership let's say search is a particular item and product numbers
is the list I want to search in I can just use the word in so let's try that now let's say it's
asking us to enter a product number I'll basically say for v475 and when I enter it says that it
found the product when I run it again and I say something like x123 then it's not going to be
found basically the idea is to simply you know take a particular element let's say in this case
q143 and say in prodnums so that's going to give me a true because q143 is present in prodnums as a
list however if I try something else which is x123 in prodnums that is not the case so I simply use
this syntax element in list it either gives me a true or false depending on whether that value is
actually present in the list or not right there we are the next and perhaps the most important
thing that you do with the list is iterate on that list we might want to take a specific action
for every element that is present in the list so let's say that I have a list which is our sales
as usual what I do is I simply create a counter which I give it the initial value of 1 and I say
that as I loop through this list I'm just going to print out that and increment the counter so
let's run this and see what it does so it basically tells me that my first month second month third
month had sales of 250, 180, 360 and so on until the list is exhausted and the syntax for doing
that is simply called a for loop so what I can simply do is for x in sales by month I can then
do something with x that will basically give my x which becomes one member at a time so generally
the syntax is like this so like for element in my list do something and element will be one of the
things that is present in the list and it's going to keep on iterating so that's basically the
syntax that I can use to do this now you see lists have a bunch of different methods attached
to them methods are nothing but functions that are attached to certain types of objects so
essentially a method in Python is simply a function except that it is very very tightly
coupled with an object it can only operate on a particular type of object so functions are called
in the following way I can say that I have a function so I have something like my function
and I give it an input of x but method on the other hand is called like this x dot myfuck so
the name of the function precedes succeeds the name of the object one quick way within
an IPython environment like the one you see here to check what all the methods are available on
a given object is something simply like this I know that I have sales by month as a list I can
just put a dot next to it and I can press tab so it gives me a bunch of different things so these
are all the functions and you can see that it's calling itself a function right so what I mean
by this is that append is a function clear is a function copy is a function count is a function
all of these functions are applicable on lists and of course if I were to use something other
which was not a list it will give me functions that are not present that are present for that
particular element right so let's create a list which is simply arrange from 1 to 6 which will
create a range from 1 to 5 and there we are so we have a list of integers from 1 to 5 the dot
append method is used to add elements to this so let's say I just want to add another element over
here now I can do a dot append and whatever input I give that's going to become the next element in
that list so I just say dot append 30 it's going to give me 1 2 3 4 5 30 so let's try that and there
we are we have 1 2 3 4 5 comma 30 pop is basically a function that is just going to pop off the last
one so when I use pop note that I haven't given it anything so by default if you give it no input
it's just going to pop out the very last element in the list so it's going to pop out 30 and we
get our original list back if I wanted to pop out a particular element at a particular location then
I can give that location as an input so when I say a dot pop 3 it's going to remove the element
at position 3 here too remember that positions are 0 starting they are not starting from 1 so
we have 0 1 2 3 so it's going to remove 4 and I'm going to get a list which is 1 2 3 and 5 so
let's try that and there it is it basically removed the element that was present at a particular
position now this was an example of how you remove an element from a list based on its position in
the list how about if I want to remove a position from the list based on its value now I can use
the remove function for that it's basically going to find the element 2 and remove it from the list
so basically now I'm going to get 1 3 and 5 so if I do this you see that it did not remove the element
at the second position but it removed the element which had a value of 2 so this is removing by
position and this is removing by value this might be a critical difference and might become very
useful in certain programming's you can always ask what if 2 is not present at all or what if you
know 3 is beyond the length of the list itself so in those cases it's going to raise an error so
for example I know that the number 0 is not present if I do a dot remove of 0 it's going to
say a value error it's basically going to say that X is not in list which means whatever you
have given as an input it's not in the list right at the same time if I use a has a length of 3 what
if I say a dot pop 9 now it clearly doesn't have 9 elements in it so this is also going to fail let's
see what happens so I say it says index out of range right so what this means is that whatever
position we are asking it to pop from the list that position is completely out of the range of
the list itself the inverse of that is insert it's basically going to add an element at a specific
location remember that append will always add to the end of the list whereas insert is going to add
an element to a specific position in the list now we have 1 3 and 5 and so we have 0 1 and 2 elements
3 is simply going to add another element at the third position right so let's try that so now we
have 1 3 5 20 now of course this is the same as append what if we wanted to do something even
more specific which is like I can also do something like a dot insert I want to add something at the
zeroth position and I can add let's say I want to add the value 0 itself at the zeroth position
and then my a becomes this if I want to add something at say the second position so I can say
insert 2 at the second position or let me add a bigger number just to avoid confusion let's say
I want to insert the number 42 at the second position so then it becomes my list then becomes
something like this at the second position which is actually the third position the number 42 has
been added and then the last one of the most important methods that you can do on a list is
sorting of the list so I can just use the sort function or the sort method on a list
and it's going to by default do an ascending sort so there it is I get the ascendingly sorted
list back if I want to change it to a descending order I can just flip the list now in order to
reverse a list I can do this or I can do something called a dot reverse and then print a again so now
it's becoming an descending list one very useful and somewhat confusing thing when working with
lists is copying them so let's say that a is a list which goes again from one to five as we
created earlier then we create another variable b and simply assign it to a and then we created
another variable c and do an a dot copy now what we're going to do is we are going to set the last
value inside a to 20 now the last value inside a should be 6 minus 1 that is 5 but we are going
to set the value to 20 so basically change the last element in e to 20 and then we print b and c
so let's see what happens so you see when the first print which is printing of b here we see that
because a has changed b also has changed but when we print c we see that c itself has not changed
because we did an explicit copy over here so when you copy a list it basically copies over all the
value but doesn't change it whereas if you just do an assignment it's basically a copy by reference
it's not a copy by value it's just going to pass around the pointer to the list so basically b will
remain the same thing as a as long as you don't copy it whereas c will remain the original copy
of a no matter what you do with it so that's basically one thing you have to keep in mind
when you're copying lists from one variable to another variable here's again the next
exercise let's say we want to create a list containing the first 20 positive integers this
we have already done and then we want to create another list containing that squares so there are
two things here creating the first step is straightforward we have already done that
in the second list we want basically all the squares of the elements in the first list now
we already know how to create how to iterate through a list and we can also create once we
have a list how do you append elements to it so basically there are two things that you have to
use for this exercise one is iteration and the second is the append method so let's pause the
video over here and try it out so this is how we do it let's say that we have n which is a list of
range of 1 to 21 and that gives me just the n which is so far correct now what I'm going to
do is create a new list so I will call it squares and for now I'm going to keep it an empty list and
then I'm going to iterate over n so I can do something like this for number in n I can
do something like square equal to number times number and then squares dot append square so now
I have another list which contains the square of all the other numbers which are inside it
and I can simply look at it again and I see that I get the squares 1 4 9 16 and so on all the way
up to 400 so there are two things we have covered here one is how to do iteration and the second is
using append to append to an empty list
here's another exercise let's say that we want to find the median of a list of numbers we have
already studied a few things about the median it's basically the middle point in a sorted list of
numbers so what we're going to do is basically create a random list of numbers and try to use
all the methods that we have seen so far to find out what is the
median of that set of numbers so again as usual pause the video try it out and
resume the video whenever you're ready to check the solution
so let's just create our original data first let's say I have a list L which contains a random set
of numbers let's just say 1 4 5 8 3 and 9 now I want the median of all of this so what I'm going
to do is simply do l dot sort to sort it and then I need to figure out what is the midpoint of L
now the problem is that there is no midpoint because it has exactly an even number of numbers
it has six elements so in that case what I do is basically I let's take a look at the sorted
list and that's my sorted list what I have to do is I know that you know I can't straight away
take the middle value because there is no middle value this is an even number of elements so I
have to take the third and the fourth element and take their average so what I'm going to do is take
the third number or actually that would mean two in this case and then take the second number or
the fourth number which would mean three and take the average so I'm just going to add them and
divide them by two and that's fine so that's basically the median of my list let's actually
verify that with some of the inbuilt functions that are available in python we can just import
a library called numpy which stands for numerical python we'll see this library in a lot more detail
and I can just do numpy dot median of L and see that it gives me the same result now of course
two and three is something that I picked just by looking at the data what if we wanted to
make this programmatic so what we can do is we essentially now have to deal with two sorts of
conditions one when the number of elements in L is essentially even and one when it is odd so the
first thing I need to do is check whether the number of elements in L is even or odd so I can
do something like small l is basically the length of L we know that length is something we can use
to calculate the length of a list now I need to figure out whether L is an even number or an odd
number so one of the things I can do is try to see if its remainder after it is divided by two is
zero or not so this percent operator is basically also called the modulus operator in python what
it does is that when you use this operator whatever is to the right hand side that becomes
the divider of whatever is to the left hand side and it basically gives me the remainder
when that division is carried out so when I say that L percent two equal to zero what I'm trying
to say is that after you divide L by two is the remainder zero or not so I can do something like
this if L percent two is zero then do something with even length else because there can only be
a one other alternative I can say something like do something with odd length now what did we do
with even length we basically took well the length was say six and half of it is three
so then I took two and three so I can do something like this then print I can do something like length
is already sorted so I can divide the whole thing into L by two so yeah I can do something like
the cutoff point becomes L by two and that becomes
L of L by two minus one because we start from zero and then plus L of L by two
which is simply the next number and then I take its average so that becomes my median
and if I have an odd length then doing it should be straightforward I can just take one out of the
length of the list divided by two L minus one so let's say I had seven elements let's add a one
over here so what I would do is seven minus one is six and then I take six divided by two would
be three and then I just take the fourth element which is one plus three so basically L minus one
divided by two and I'll leave it like that because the plus one which we require to get to this
number and the zero indexing in Python they cancel each other out so that becomes my center point
and then just becomes L indexed by this particular case and then I'll just say print
okay and obviously we have a type error over here well this should have game within brackets
because without brackets what it did was it simply tried to do a one by two you know by the Bordemus
rules and that becomes 0.5 and you can't use floats to index a list so there it is
let's enclose this within brackets and there it is also this is still causing a problem it seems
so L minus one divided by two is not working out
let us try it out so we know that L is basically seven and L minus one divided by two
ah so we see that it's giving us a floating point number I need to convert it into an integer so
that's what converts it into an integer
there it is but then at the same time I will have to convert these things into an integer into
integers as well because those two are basically going to give me floating point values and you
can't use floating point values to index a list you can't use float because a list doesn't have
floating point positions it only has integer positions obviously so there we are so now we
have a median of four and let's try it out again here we also have a median of four so that's
basically the strategy to excuse me find out the median out of a list of numbers with pure python
of course later you'll realize that you can just use this simple function as it is
but this basically is just an exercise to show you how lists work
so
now the next most important data structure that we're going to see is something called a tuple
so a tuple is exactly like a list it's a sequence that simply resembles a list except
unlike a list it is immutable that is it cannot be changed so for example I create a tuple
and after that I can never change it until I create a new one so once I create this tuple
called warehouse there is absolutely nothing I can do with this and the only difference between
a tuple and a list or at least in the way that we create them is that instead of square brackets we
add down brackets so basically one way to see why a tuple is immutable we can again use the same
trick as before to figure out what are the functions that are available for a tuple if I
do a warehouse dot and press tab I see that it gives me only two functions whereas on a list
which is like you know L is a list I see a ton of different functions so basically tuples are
basically used to create data that is supposed to be read only something that you don't want
to change something that is constant right so there we are and I can use only two things I
can say that you know I want to do an append let's say New York it's a tuple of cities
it doesn't say it just says that you know tuple object has no attribute append won't allow that
at the same time if I want to change Chicago to New York I know that the zeroth element is Chicago
what if I want to change it to New York it says that tuple object does not support item assignment
so essentially it's going to let us do absolutely nothing with this video yeah we can only read it
we can't write to it or we can iterate through it of course we can say that for w in warehouse
that it lets me do but pretty much anything it can't do it can only read from data it can't
write back right another important and you know probably from a data science perspective from a
data analytics perspective the most important data structure that we are going to look at is
something called a dictionary so dictionary is basically python's implementation of what is
otherwise known in computer science either as an associative array or a hash table or a lookup
right so it's essentially just something that contains a collection of key value pairs there
are a bunch of values and all of them are addressable with a key as we saw in tuples and lists the
values are accessible by their location by their index here there is no such thing as position or
location there is simply a key that you use to open a particular value that's it so and the way
you create that is you use a pair of braces and you have a key and you put a colon and next to
that you create a value so basically let's say that we have we want to store a bunch of phone
numbers of a bunch of people and we have two people here called savannah and nathaniel so i
say that savannah's phone number is this and nathaniel's phone number is this so i use a
pair of square braces savannah and nathaniel become my keys i put a colon next to them and
then i put in the values right so that's what it would look like there it is what this tells me
is that savannah is my key and that person has this phone number and nathaniel is another key
and that person has this phone number now of course why would we do this because sometimes
it's easier to remember names rather than numbers i might simply have stored these numbers and lists
but then you know i might have forgotten the zeroth number belongs to whom and the first
number belongs to whom so that's why it's sometimes easier to refer to objects by their names rather
than by their locations so of course strings are not the only thing that we can create within a
dictionary you can create integers also so let's say that i have personal details of a person
whose name is molly and the age is 25 so i can run this and you know there it is so that creates
another dictionary problem let's go through some of the common dictionary operations that we can
have in order to access a particular value from a dictionary i can use the key so for example from
info if i want to pick out the name of whoever this particular dictionary belongs to i can just
do an indexing like this note that this syntax is very similar to what we saw in the list
are a couple here if this was a list we would just have set something like zero or one or two
or something like that but remember that dictionaries have no concept of a position
all positions are independent and they are addressable only with their key and what is our
key it's basically just a string so we can just let's just copy this and put it here so that it
is it just gives me molly which is the value for the key and the key is name and what i can do is
like we had an append method earlier to add elements to a list i can add elements to a
dictionary by simply creating a new key like this so job itself doesn't exist and if it doesn't
exist it's going to get created right so let's add that and now i have that extra key value pair
name is molly age is 25 and the job is analyst what if i want to update it let's say that earlier
we added a key which did not exist sorry so it appended that key to the dictionary what if you
want to edit a key let's say that i want to change my name from molly to sally and i can just use the
same syntax over here the rule is that if this key exists it's going to get updated if it doesn't
exist it's going to get added so let's try that so now i have sally 25 and analyst it's basically
exactly the same thing as this with the exception of the name change now how do i remove a key value
pair that also you see just depends it just behaves completely like the way we saw it for list
so when we pop it we popped out the name we basically removed this entire key value pair
and now only age and job is left now let's create this again and we have put the name back in i can
also do a del which will completely delete that name
and there it is i have removed name i can do it either by popping or i can do it by deleting
whichever is more convenient depending on your application
now just like we have learned how to iterate through a list you also need to learn how to
iterate through a dictionary we know that since a list is simply a collection of elements when we
iterate through it we are just going to deal with one particular element at a time but in the case
of a dictionary what we have is not simply a sequence of elements but a sequence of key value
pairs so basically there are two things over which you can iterate you can either iterate through
keys or through values by default when you iterate through a dictionary using the same syntax you can
have something like a for key in dictionary you are going to iterate through the keys so basically
key is going to be age job name and so on and to get the corresponding value you have to use
the same syntax as we had earlier which is accessing the key by its value so basically we
can just do this we had only two keys over here so that's how we did it then there are a bunch of
other dictionary operations we can use length just like we use it on a list for a dictionary it's
just going to return the length of key value pairs note that it's not going to return the whole
length of the item stored in it but basically the length of pairs so essentially this counts as one
and this counts as two so length of info is going to be two because it has two key value pairs
and if we want to simply list all the keys in a dictionary we can do something like info dot keys
and pass it to a dictionary so here is the list of the keys similarly if we want the list to list
the values then we can do info dot values to get the values out of it so here are our keys age being
25 and job being analyst and here are our values where 25 is the value of age and analyst is the
value of job we have already seen how we remove individual elements from a particular dictionary
let's say that i want to remove only the name or only i want to use the you know only a specific
key i want to remove only a specific key i can use either a pop or a del method to do that
here if i want to remove everything inside a dictionary i can do something like clear so
essentially that just returns an empty dictionary right dictionaries are important primarily like i
said from a data science perspective because they are very useful for representing data so here is
let's say a simple dictionary that we have created data is our dictionary and we have three keys
inside that dictionary one is called name the other is industry and the third is funding in
us dollars the values of each of these keys are essentially lists here name is a list of three
startups industry is basically the industry that you know that particular startup operates in and
funding usd is again a list but this time it's a list of integers because funding is numbers so you
can use lists you can use integers to represent them what we have is three keys and each value
is basically a list which has a length of three what do you think this represents if you think
carefully you'll see that this basically represents a table right so which has essentially three
columns and three rows so let's try that we can use the pandas library to convert this dictionary
into an actual table we'll be dealing with pandas in a lot more detail in some of the upcoming
videos so that's basically what it represents when i put this dictionary inside pandas every
key becomes a column and the values basically become the values of those columns so essentially
name which is by juice flip carton shuttle appears here by juice flip carton shuttle
and correspondingly the industry and the funding appear like the industry and the funding columns
so this is one way of representing tabular data with a dictionary the alternative is to basically
create a list of dictionaries itself what we did here was we created a dictionary where the
keys were strings and the values were dictionaries the alternative is we are creating a dictionary
note that we have square braces or square bracket at the ends so this is basically a
list and know that we can put anything inside a list so in this case what we have done is that
we have put an entire dictionary inside a list so essentially we have and inside each of them
we have name industry and funding specifically called out as the key value pairs so name is by
juice industries etec funding is so much name is flip cart industries e-commerce funding is so much
name is shuttle industries transport and funding is so much so this is your classic database record
format so essentially you see that both these representations are actually representing the
same data and if we were to create again the pandas data frame it looks exactly identical
but here we have a list of dictionaries and here we have a dictionary of lists
so it's the same data being represented in two different ways and how to choose and pick between
them is basically the job of is basically one of the most important jobs of a data scientist
because when programming when writing scripts when writing especially you know scripts that
work with large amounts of data these things will become important as we will see so here's
an exercise let's say that we have one we have this data set this particular table we want to
add a column to this data set denoting the location that is mumbai bangalore and chennai
we have name industry and funding we want to add another column here which is simply mumbai bangalore
and chennai for example then what we want to do is add a row to this data set for a new startup
let's call it just atm which is in the e-payments industry so we know what to fill in the name and
we know what to fill in the industry and let's say it is located in delhi we have already added the
column for the location and let's say that it has supposedly received a funding of 42 million usd
so how do you do that we have two particular ways of doing it let's see which one is better
try out both the things and just type in the data and just use you're free to copy paste
code from anywhere in this notebook to try and finish this exercise so feel free to pause the
video here and resume when you're ready with the solution okay so let's take a look the first task
is to add a column to this data set which denotes the location so you see that the first
tree presentation which have is a column first representation in the sense that the columns are
the keys and the values in each row are simply a list so if i want to add another column i can
just use this now i'll just paste this over here and say that the column that i want to add
is simply location and then that location becomes a list of strings let's say mumbai
bangalore and chennai and then i'm just going to create a data frame out of oops
sorry i'm just going to create a data frame out of the data over here and there it is so now we
have a new column called location now what we want to do is add a row to this data set now you see
that this was a representation that was column specific so if i have to add a row over here
i'll have to go and type the individual value in each particular row so adding a row to this
data set for paytm so let's add paytm first
and which is in the e-payments industry so i some add something like e-payments it is
located in delhi so i add delhi over here and it has received a supposed funding of 42 million
so i will add something like this so there it is i have a new column and a new row right so remember
that you know if i had to add another row i had to basically modify and append each single list in
my each single column in my original data but if you were to use this particular thing this
particular syntax which is a row first syntax this time it's not a column first syntax it's
basically a row first syntax so let's try this now i just want to add a new record for paytm
so i can just do something like this name is paytm
industry is what was it e-payments
and funding
is 42 million
and then i can just do pd.dataframe.fromrecords.data
so there it is something went wrong this is not a dot it's supposed to be a comma so there we are
so here we have added a row but we missed out on the column which is the location column so if i
have to add that column again i have to do the inverse of what i did earlier basically add a
location key everywhere so location would be mumbai location then would be location for
flipkart would be something like bangor location for shuttle would be chennai
and for paytm location would be dead
so now i have an extra row and an extra column so you see when you have to add a row a certain
type of data representation is useful because i just have to type you know this much whereas
if i had to add a row in this particular case i'll have to add this then this then this in
this basically i have to change four lines whereas here i have to change only one line
on the other hand if i have to add a column then i just have to type in this much in this
particular representation but in this representation when i have to add a column i have to append this
whole bunch of text at the end of every row so depending on what your application demands
whether it is something that demands incrementing in rows versus incrementing in columns choosing
the right data structure is important if we want to go on adding columns then this is the
right data structure but if we want to go on adding rows then this is the right data structure
so you can choose between say lists of dictionaries versus dictionaries of lists depending on
what sort of updates you want to do to your data for example imagine that you have a fintech
application again as we've used this example before where you are trying to predict whether
somebody is you know eligible for a loan or something like that and you already have data
for about a thousand customers and the thousand and first customer comes in and you want to create
a row for this person then obviously this sort of representation will be better right because
you're just adding one particular dictionary for the new customer that has come however if let's
say that your ceo comes back and says that hey it looks like we have been taking all kinds of
details for each customer but we haven't exactly included their age in our table so we have their
name we have their income we have their gender but we don't have their age so now we have to add
another column so then this sort of a thing might be useful but of course once the set of
columns stabilizes you might want to move from this sort of a representation to this sort of a
representation the whole point of this entire video was to get you acquainted with data structures
and how to pick the right data structure which makes your job easier which makes your job more
flexible which makes writing code easy so accordingly depending on the application you
can pick the right data structure all the best